[Music]
where are all the monopoles what happens
when you break a magnet in two
do you get two magnets one north and one
south two so-called magnetic monopoles
there's nothing in physics classical or
quantum that says you can't and yet we
don't see that we break any magnet in
two we don't get isolated north and
south poles we get two north poles and
two south poles
and yet if you ask a particle physicist
which particle they'd most like to find
the answer is a magnetic monopole
[Music]
a magnetic monopole is a hypothetical
elementary particle one that can't be
further subdivided such particles would
be isolated north or south magnetic
poles these particles have been
hypothesized since 1931 when the eminent
physicist paul dirac showed that if
magnetic monopoles existed in the
universe then all the electric charge
which we observe in the universe to be
quantized must be quantized this is
called the dirac quantization condition
since we do observe that electric charge
is quantized we have reason to believe
that perhaps there should be magnetic
monopoles in the universe remember we
just need to find one
since dirac's iconic 1931 paper
several systematic searches for magnetic
monopoles have been performed so it
remains an open question whether
monopoles exist advances in theoretical
particle physics particularly those
developments in the so-called grand
unified theory the theory that seeks to
unify the strong and weak nuclear forces
with the electromagnetic force or even
in the theory of everything which seeks
to unify those three forces and fields
with the theory of gravity making a
so-called quantum theory of gravity they
have yet to be found in fact the late
great physicist joseph paul chinsky of
university of california santa barbara
said one of the safest predictions about
physics not yet seen is the existence of
a monopole now why do physicists want
these particular presents
it's because both the grand unified
theories and super string theories are
perhaps our greatest hope for unifying
all the laws of physics into one master
equation as past guest michio kaku said
perhaps only one inch long that he calls
the god equation because that's an
experimental problem
in other words it's your fault right
magnetic fields and electric fields are
interchangeable in maxwell's theory of
electromagnetism so what happens when
you break apart a magnet into two do you
get one north pole and one south pole on
the same magnet or do you get two north
poles and two south poles let's do it
nope you get a north pole and a south
pole and a north pole in a south pole
the question is why now the first
systematic search for these types of
hypothesized particles using modern day
technology took place in 1982 it was
valentine's day at stanford university
and physicist blas cabrera had
undertaken
an incredible experiment with ultra high
precision to search out for these
elusive particles he took a loop of a
superconducting material he put it in an
ultra-low magnetic field container and
he monitored the current that was
induced through this loop using what's
called a superconducting quantum
interference device
or squid amplifier what blas was able to
do was search for individual quantum
units of magnetic flux induced in the
superconducting coil and on valentine's
day 1982 he found it
a single event
consistent with one dirac unit of
magnetic charge the monopole had been
found soon after rumors spread of blas's
discovery like wildfire and in april the
organizers of a workshop on grand
unification phone cabrera in blacksburg
virginia where he was giving a
colloquium and they said please come and
address this workshop the next day
after an all-night drive to chapel hill
blas electrified the audience there was
only one problem after blas reported his
results no one could confirm them
now had blas actually discovered the
single monopole that exists in our
entire universe
well mother nature didn't reciprocate
the love that particular valentine's day
and little has changed in the 40 years
since
but physicists are still searching
the answer may come down
to
that of beauty but if we could unify
together the laws of electricity and
magnetism and and find an instantiation
of the magnetic charge in the same way
that we know the electric charge exists
we'd have perfect symmetry between
electric and magnetic fields there's
nothing in classical physics or quantum
physics that says these things cannot
exist beauty is in the eye of the
beholder
if these monopoles existed you could
interchange the electric terms in
maxwell's equations with the magnetic
terms it would be perfect symmetry and
so beautiful so physicists don't give up
easily in pursuing their loves a team at
cern's large hadron collider has
recently established one of the most
incredible mass limits for the still
elusive hypothesized magnetic monopole
particle they did so by creating the
biggest magnetic field ever observed in
the entire universe
this collaboration known as modal
which stands for the monopole and
exotics detector at the large hadron
collider lhc using ions of lead
colliding together the experiment
succeeded by producing a magnetic field
with a strength of 10 to the 16th tesla
over 10 to the 20th times bigger than
the magnetic field here on earth the
modal experiment uses what's called the
schwinger
mechanism
[Music]
this is somewhat analogous to the bright
wigner effect that we spoke about in a
previous video carried out at the
relativistic heavy ion collider or rick
experiment
the schwinger effect technically
involves the production of electrons and
positrons the antimatter analog of
electrons this electron positron pair
production is replaced in the modal
experiment using decaying magnetic
fields that could create magnetic
monopoles and they're anti-particles so
decaying electric fields produce
electron positron pairs and the modal
experiments looking for the decay of
magnetic fields which would produce
magnetic monopoles and their
antiparticles these experimentalists
examine almost 2 billion lead ion
collisions
with a 5 terra electron volt center of
mass energy per collision
this was carrying out in 2018 when they
used a superconducting quantum
interference device the squid amplifiers
same ones that blas cabrera used in
principle back in the valentine's day
event 1982 they use this as a
magnetometer to scan what's called a
trapping detector looking for the
trapped presence of a magnetic charge
this charge the monopole would induce a
persistent current in the squid
to which they would be exquisitely
sensitive too now this would happen if
the trap contained a magnetic monopole
or if the magnetic monopole actually
existed they looked for integer charges
of magnetic field and this magnetic
charge if you will comes in so-called
dirac units and they look for up to
three of these dirac units and although
no magnetic monopoles were spotted the
team did exclude the range of possible
monopoles for all monopoles with masses
smaller than 75 gev and that's roughly
80 times as large as the mass of the
proton so why don't we see these
magnetic monopoles using the most
advanced detector ever made by human
beings could it be that as some
theoreticians suggest
magnetic monopoles are simply too
massive to be created by these ion ion
collisions even using the most advanced
collider ever made or perhaps the most
advanced clutter that we can ever make
as usual on this channel we don't
mourn
a result that doesn't make a detection
some of those are the most important
discoveries because they narrow the
range for our theoretician friends and
colleagues to pursue i see this as an
absolute win which then gives us tighter
limits and we create a flywheel that we
can then use to refine and hopefully
detect something but even if we don't
it's still a success
the future results will look for even
larger ranges of magnetic monopoles
they'll deploy a new detector at the lhc
to look for magnetic monopoles with
higher and higher masses and higher and
higher magnetic charges
why don't we see them perhaps it's
because there's only a handful literally
as predicted by several early universe
theories there may have been many
magnetic monopoles but due to inflation
they really get inflated out of our
cosmic observable horizon so we don't
actually observe them even though they
do exist leave your best guess in the
comments below and don't forget to sign
up for my free twice monthly magic
monday message where i share ideas from
around the world of experimental physics
consciousness the brain and searches for
extraterrestrial life in the cosmos if
you enjoyed this video about magnetic
monopoles i know you're gonna love this
playlist that i've curated just for you
describes the fascinating world of
searching for other exotic phenomena
just like the one you just enjoyed click
here don't forget to subscribe